[Music]  five tips for polaroid look  tip number one  close the aperture to get rid of the  bokeh because polaroids have very little  bokeh tip number two defocus  set your camera to manual focus and set  the focus point just in front of subject  tip number three d sharpen tip number  four soft clipping crush the highlights  and shadows to soften detail and  contrast tip number five this is the  last step use funky colors you can check  the internet for some tips regarding the  color science or just watch my video  tutorials to learn more  bonus use low shadow to gain motion blur  and more softening effect  need more inspiration go check my  instagram for my latest work and some  funky color schemes you can try yourself  have fun  [Music]